Hey, can you turn it up?
I feel like Neo.
Why, because you're the chosen one?
I could be the chosen one.
You don't know.
But no, that's not what I meant.
What did you mean?
Just that the world feels off to me.
Like how?
It's kinda hard to explain.
Like it's artificial somehow.
Like we're dreaming all this through a computer
system and our physical bodies are just being
used as batteries.
Well, I don't know.
I don't know, that's the point.
I just know that something's wrong... something
not right with the world.
Yeah, it's called humanity.
It's like we're living in an artificial world,
oblivious to the real world going on around
us.
I think you just watch too many sci-fi movies.
Didn't you do a marathon last weekend of sci-fi
films?
Yeah, I did The Matrix, Dark City, The 13th
Floor, Inception, and Men in Black.
Yeah, all movies that deal with alternate
realities.
I don't think I get your point.
It's like whenever you watch a bunch of scary
movies and then you want to climb into my
bed and sleep 'cause you're scared?
You watched all these movies that have a fake
reality, and now you're convinced your reality
is fake.
You're talking yourself into this, can't you
see that?
I guess that's possible.
Who, deja vu.
What?
Where?
What happened?
There was an orange cat, and then another
one just like it.
How much like it?
Was it the same cat?
A deja vu is usually a glitch in the Matrix!
Holy sh*t!
Calm down, calm down.
We have two orange cats.
They're twins.
Remember?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you're right.
For a second there my world almost came crashing
down around me.
What does it matter if it's all fake?
So you're admitting that it's all fake?
No.
I was being sarcastic.
You need to learn not to take me so seriously.
You know, sarcasm is also usually a glitch
in the Matrix.
I'm with the guy in the hat.
They're both wearing hats.
The guy on the right, the guy in the beanie.
That figures, he's even stupider than you
are.
Thanks!